saludos a ustedes y también a todas
nuestras de la audiencia real pues sí 36
por ciento de los franceses espera con
impaciencia el debate televisado entre
emmanuel ma con imagine depende según
las últimas encuestas pero sólo 14%
reconoce que el enfrentamiento de esta
noche será decisivo en su voto fueron 16
millones y medio de telespectadores
quienes presenciaron el debate entre los
mismos aspirantes en 2017 y se espera
una cifra similar esta noche algunos
temas del debate se decidieron por
sorteo porque los equipos de campaña no
se pusieron de acuerdo primero el más
esperado poder adquisitivo y luego
asuntos internacionales el modelo social
es decir la reforma de pensiones y la
salud el medio ambiente educación
seguridad y cuestiones de gobernabilidad
entre otros ahora si miramos las
encuestas a pocas horas de ese único
debate presidencial marco sigue siendo
el favorito de estos comicios según
ipsos opr asteria el actual jefe de
estado ganaría con 56 por ciento frente
a 44 de marine lepén una ventaja de casi
13 puntos porcentuales son números
un poco apenas un punto porcentual por
semana eso sí a favor del presidente
otro asunto importante como lo
mencionaba continúa la batalla por ganar
los votos de elección en la primera
vuelta casi 22% del total pues cerca de
la mitad de los simpatizantes de mel en
sión no sabe aún si votará o si se
abstendrá es una problemática que podría
también estar alimentada por la nueva
ofensiva del líder de francia- insumisa
de restar importancia a la segunda
vuelta a propósito de pensiones miguel
como lo estábamos hablando él hizo un
llamado a votar masivamente por él y se
propuso como el primer ministro que está
pasando con esto que nos puede decir al
respecto
pues si el líder de francia insumisas
rompió un relativo silencio mediático de
cerca de 10 días para regresar a por
todo al ring político en la noche de
temprana elección compareció ante las
cámaras de bf en tv y anunció esto pido
a los franceses que me elijan primer
ministro para ello les pido elegir una
mayoría de diputados insumisos y esto
por supuesto de cara a la llamada
tercera vuelta de la elección
presidencial la legislativa que tendrá
lugar en junio próximo y de nuevo por
supuesto la pregunta sería esto posible
pues bien aquí en francia el primer
ministro es designado por el presidente
de la república aunque no esté
expresamente escrito en la constitución
se admite que cuando se elija a la
asamblea una mayoría que se oponga al
presidente el premier debe provenir de
sus filas y hay ejemplos de ello en 1997
la izquierda ganó las elecciones
legislativas de junio y lionel jospin
del partido socialista fue nombrado
primer ministro por jacques chirac
presidente de derecha fue la tercera
cohabitación de ellos de la actual
república soñar no cuesta nada en todo
caso el principal obstáculo de esa
es lograr una mayoría en la asamblea muy
difícil a pesar de que varios partidos
han mostrado interés en esa iniciativa
francia en su misa tiene en este momento
17 diputados y unión popular la unión
popular propuesta por mélenchon debe
conquistar más de 250 entre
representantes insumisos y de otros
partidos para que todo esto que hemos
explicado comience a aparecer posible